Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This paper will not have the visual fireworks
that you see in many of our videos. Oftentimes,
you get ice cream for the eyes, but today,
you’ll get an ice cream for the mind. And,
when I read this new paper,
I almost fell off the chair,
and I think this work teaches us important
lessons and I hope you will appreciate them too.
So, with that, let’s talk about AIs and dealing
with text! This research field is improving at an
incredible pace. For instance, four years ago,
in 2017, scientists at OpenAI embarked on an AI
project where they wanted to show a neural network
a bunch of Amazon product reviews and wanted to
teach it to be able to generate new ones, or
continue a review when given one. Upon closer
inspection, they noticed that the neural network
has built up a knowledge of not only language,
but also learned that it needs to create a
state-of-the-art sentiment detector as well.
This means that the AI recognized that in order to
be able to continue a review, it needs to be able
to understand English, and efficiently detect
whether the review seems positive or negative.
This new work is about text summarization, and it
really is something else. If you read reddit, the
popular online discussion website, and encounter
a longer post, you may also find a short summary,
a TLDR of the same post, written by a fellow
human. This is good for not only the other readers
who are in a hurry, but, it is less obvious
is that it is also good for something else.
And now, hold on to your papers, because
these summaries also provide fertile
grounds for a learning algorithm to read a
piece of long text, and its short summary,
and learn how the two relate to each other.
This means that it can be used as training
data and can be fed to a learning algorithm.
Yum! And the point is that if we give enough
of these pairs to these learning algorithms,
they will learn to summarize other reddit posts.
So, let’s see how well it performs. First,
this method learned on about a hundred thousand
well-curated reddit posts, and was also tested
on other posts that it hadn’t seen before. It
was asked to summarize this post from relationship
advice subreddit, and let’s see how well it did.
If you feel like reading the text, you
can pause the video here, or if you feel
like embracing the TLDR spirit, just carry
on, and look at these two summarizations.
One of these is written by a human, and the other
one by this new summarization technique. Do you
know which is which? Please stop the video and let
me know in the comments below. Thank you! So this,
was written by a human and this by the new
AI. And while, of course, this is subjective,
I would say that the AI-written one feels at
the very least as good as the human summary,
and I can’t wait to have a look at the
more principled evaluation in the paper.
Let’s see…the higher we go here, the higher the
probability of a human favoring the AI-written
summary to a human-written one. And we have
smaller AI models on the left, bigger ones to
the right. This is the 50% reference line, below
it, people tend to favor the human’s version,
and if it can get above the 50% line, the
AI does a better job than human-written
TLDRs in the dataset. Here are two proposed
models, this one significantly underperforms,
this other one is a better match. However,
whoa! Look at that! The authors also proposed a
human feedback model that, even for the smallest
model, handily outperforms human-written TLDRs,
and as we grow the AI model, it gets even
better than that. Now that’s incredible,
and this is when I almost fell off
the chair when reading this paper.
But! We’re not done yet, not even close. Don’t
forget, this AI was trained on reddit, and was
also tested on reddit. So our next question is,
of course, can it do anything else? How general
is the knowledge that it gained? What if we
give it a full news article from somewhere else,
outside of reddit? Let’s see how it performs.
Hmm…of course, this is also subjective, but I
would say both are quite good. The human-written
summary provides a little more information,
while the AI-written one captures the essence of
the article and does it very concisely. Great job.
So, let’s see the same graph for summarizing
these articles outside reddit. I don’t expect
the AI to perform as well as with the reddit
posts as it is outside the comfort zone,
but…my goodness, this still performs nearly
as well as humans. That means that it indeed
derived general knowledge from a really narrow
training set, which is absolutely amazing. Now,
ironically, you see this Lead-3 technique
dominating both humans and the AI. What could that
be? Some unpublished, superintelligent technique?
Well, I will have to disappoint, this is not a
super sophisticated technique, but a dead simple
one. So simple that it is just taking the first
three sentences of the article, which humans seem
to prefer a great deal. But note, that this simple
Lead-3 technique only works for a narrow domain,
while the AI has learned the English language,
probably knows about sentiment, and a lot
of other things that can be used elsewhere.
And now, the two most impressive
things from the paper, in my opinion:
One, this is not a neural network, but a
reinforcement learning algorithm that learns
from human feedback. A similar technique has been
used by DeepMind and other research labs to play
video games or control drones and it is really
cool to see them excel in text summarization too.
Two, it learned from humans, but derived so much
knowledge from these scores, that over time,
it outperformed its own teacher. And the
teacher here is not humans in general,
but people who write TLDRs along their posts
on reddit. That truly feels like something
straight out of a science fiction
movie. What a time to be alive!
Now, of course, not even this technique is
perfect, this human vs AI preference thing
is just one way of measuring the quality of the
summary, there are more sophisticated methods
that involve coverage, coherence, accuracy, and
more. In some of these measurements, the AI does
not perform as well. But just imagine what this
will be able to do two more papers down the line.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!